here now with more on his announcement
that he will be sending National Guard
troops to Texas Florida Governor Ronda
santis Governor great to have you back I
know you stuck with me now I apologize
in advance but I I vote the right way
and I didn't bring any New York uh
opinions with me I promise you uh it's
great to be in the Free State of Florida
so you know
Sean just so you know we just got ranked
uh a couple days ago number one in
America for the places to retire and
just for the record that is after you
relocated here so I think that's the
hanity effect in action Florida number
one for retirement yet again if I had a
dollar for every person that I know that
contacted me and said I'm following you
I'm going to be down there I'm I'm going
to be right behind you uh I I'd be
pretty wealthy you picked a good spot
obviously uh the governance that you're
seeing here is is Miles different than
what you saw in New York and this border
is actually a good issue I mean Bill
maluan pointed out we were the first we
said we've sent people continuously
since 2021 as soon as Biden reversed
policies as soon as he embraced an open
border we knew this was going to be a
big issue so we've responded to calls
from Texas throughout the years uh and
then I think with this issue with this
wire and the fortifications I just
wanted to make sure if we could send
additional Personnel to help Texas put
up as much of this wire or barricades as
possible to be able to drive those
numbers to zero well I'm going to step
up and do it I think they're doing the
absolute right thing by standing their
ground they have every right to defend
the sovereignty of their state and yes
we've seen massive numbers of people
flooding New York City we've seen crime
drugs all that stuff is very significant
but it's also a fundamental issue a
country has borders if you don't have a
border you are not a country and Biden
has failed at his duty as commander-in
Chief uh to make sure our laws are
Faithfully executed so we have every
right as states to band together and do
the job that the federal government
refuses to do you know look we see this
a lot with States during natural time
times of natural disaster if you the
hurricane in Florida you know how many
electric companies from around the
country will descend on Florida to help
you get your power up and running as
quickly as possible uh and they'll stage
outside of wherever that hurricane is
landing and they'll be there to help I
really believe that this Friday deadline
that Joe Biden had put out there I'm not
sure he might not I'm not sure he
wouldn't have acted had it not been for
people like you and every other
Republican governor coming out speaking
out supporting Governor Abbott and
standing in solidarity with him because
at that point there was strength and
numbers and and you were one of the
first out of the box to do it uh I think
that played a big role well not only
that I mean you have a situation where
just imagine the political optic Sean to
have the federal government forcibly
removing barriers and then letting
people flood in illegally I mean it's
absolutely insane you know we've had
people on the ground now for a number of
years and I was able to talk about some
of the stories that our Personnel have
reported there was an illegal alien that
took a one-year-old baby and threw the
baby into the Rio Grand to try to lure a
boat to come so that he could jump on
the boat and get across the border there
was a woman with him through a
four-year-old in so the boat had to come
and rescue these people didn't let him
come across the border of course but the
fact that you see stuff like this his
policy is not only bad for America it's
a humanitarian
disaster I think one of the interesting
moments when you debated Gavin Nome here
on this show is when we were talking
about the issue of sanctuary States
illegal immigration and when you had
gotten people to sign permission slips
before you sent them to moth's Vineyard
where by the way they were thrown off
that Island in less than 24 hours even
though our team investigated and there
were rooms for every one of them but
they went voluntarily uh and and he
thought that maybe you should be
investigated for kidnapping uh that was
a pretty humorous moment to me
anyway well but the thing about it
though is is you know you the reason why
we have open borders is because of
liberal Elites in this country it's
ideological and it's fine for them to do
it when they don't have to suffer any
consequences of it but as you saw with
the Martha Vineyard once 50 illegal
aliens showed up it was like a major
crisis and they got off that island and
you're right it wasn't even in season so
they had massive numbers of rooms
Manhattan they used to Virtue signal
when Trump was President about how
everybody's welcome nobody's illegal
then you start to have people there it
it crimps the services and so now
they're complaining about it so I think
what all this has just shown is open
borders doesn't work you have liberal
Democrat voters now throughout this
country who agree with us which was not
the case five or six years ago so let's
get this job done I hope Congress will
authorize the funding of the border wall
um and and I hope that Biden will uh be
shamed in the actually taking action
although I definitely wouldn't put money
on that now you do have to wonder I mean
with the razor wire and the other
barricades that Governor Abbott and
Texas have put up and and by the way you
you're assisting I know Governor
Christine Nome has pledged to send down
razor wire so they can build more
barriers uh but if you listen to Bill
malan's report you know he's talking
about now the illegal immigration uh
problem is lessening in Texas and it's
now ratcheting up in Arizona and
California now my advice to illegal
immigrants if they're going to pick a
state they should pick the friendliest
State that's Gavin Nome State I think
every single illegal immigrant should
make their way to California Gavin is
promising free health care for every
illegal immigrant uh you're not going to
be sent back it's it's Sanctuary you'll
never be asked your status and you get
free healthc care courtesy of California
taxpayers I think Gavin is basically
saying better as an illegal alien
they'll treat you better as an illegal
alien if you show up in California then
they will if if you or I showed up Sean
it's just American citizens and think
about what we're now seeing at airport
uh if you want to go into airport
through TSA uh you've got to obviously
show ID they they search you all this
stuff these illegals they don't even
have photo ID and they're allowed to go
and fly on Commercial Air flights uh so
they actually have preferential
treatment in this country which is just
a total farce so yes California would be
the place to go but however Sean I will
say this we're all Americans we're going
to continue to fortify Texas I'd like to
see those numbers go to zero but if
California actually wants to stop people
coming across the border I'm happy to
send to California as well because
ultimately I want the whole border
secure Texas is the first step but we
need all states to have secure borders I
listen I think that would extend your
friendship with Governor Nome um what is
law enforcement in in Florida for
example in these Sanctuary cities and
states you're not allowed to ask
somebody's status um if somebody gets
pulled over they don't have an ID they
don't have anything and and and maybe
they're from a another country maybe
they can't communicate with a police
officer uh do do law enforcement in
Florida have the right to check their
status and if they are in the country
illegally what is Florida
doing of course we we are not a
sanctuary State and we have banned
Sanctuary cities and so if you have a
Criminal Alien in possession for example
ice has a detainer uh they have to under
state law turn the Criminal Alien over
to ice I brought up the incidents when
we had the debate with Gavin um that you
moderated there was a Criminal Alien who
had been deported multiple times in La
there was an ice detainer that wanted to
take this Criminal Alien and Deport and
he had been multiple crimes La refused
to honor the detainer so instead of
turning him over to Federal immigration
authorities they released the Criminal
Alien into the community what happened
that criminal illegal alien murdered the
mother of a three-year-old child so
these policies are dangerous uh we don't
support that in Florida and if our local
governments uh would try to be Sanctuary
we would have uh recourse because it
violates Florida law I really mean this
I I think if it wasn't for you and the
other Republican Governors coming to the
aid of Governor Abbott um I really think
Joe Biden was setting up a potential
confrontation between border patrol and
Texas National Guard and I I don't even
like the thought of it um and thankfully
the CBP or officers are like no way they
are our fellow law enforcement we
respect what they're doing we appreciate
what they're doing so it didn't work out
the way Joe wanted Governor good to see
you thank you we appreciate your time
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else